hi i'm lucy today i'll be unboxing the
playstation 5. this
is the version that comes with the disk
drive this is not the digital only
version
obviously comes in quite a big box uh
and i will immediately own up to the
fact that i did
accidentally tear it um when i was
trying to get it out of the box that it
came in it came in a fedex delivery
so maybe that's a warning to you that
the the outside packaging is quite thin
if we turn it around we get a better
look at some of the things that will be
inside obviously the console
and the brand new dual sense controller
okay let's open her up i've got a razor
blade
okay
not even joking just ripped it again a
little bit there
very very light packaging on the outside
okay
first up
okay we've got the accessories box uh we
have the quick start guide
or the printed materials to get your
playstation 5 set up at the beginning
uh also the safety guides all your
safety notes
to be aware of i suppose the power cable
pretty standard ac power cable there and
then
[Music]
ah the base of the system so
let me open this up so the playstation 5
base can be attached in
two different locations on the console
you can either put it
so it's standing upright or you can put
it so it is laying down
flat and uh if we look inside
we can see this is where we keep the
screw
very cool so uh depending on where you
want to put your base
uh you always have a spot to save the
screw in hdmi cable to connect your
console to
tv in here we have the charging cable
for the dual sense controller it is
a regular usb to usbc but
this is what we're here for the brand
new dualsense controller
so on first impressions just looking at
the controller
it is not as bright white as i thought
it was going to be from all the
marketing and everything we've seen in
the playstation 5
so far i genuinely thought this was
going to be a bright white it actually
has more of a
grayish tinge to it when you're looking
at it uh
in real life so first impressions it
feels really nice in the hand it feels
very familiar if you've been playing on
a dualshock 4 a lot
it just feels a bit sturdier a little
bit heavier
let's start with the charging port we've
already seen the charging cable usb c
it's right at the back there
in terms of the face buttons they have
lost all their color
probably to fit in with this new sleek
black and white look
so shoulder buttons there's a little
more sound feedback when you're pressing
them which actually feels quite nice
they feel like way more responsive i
don't know if it's just because my dual
shock 4 is quite old and it feels a
little bit sticky the face buttons are
actually
a lot softer to press and actually the
touchpad has more of a feedback in it as
well the
dualshock 4 touchpad felt very very soft
to me but this one feels like it's
way more of a button but the face
buttons themselves do feel a lot softer
to press
the thumb sticks have rubber textures on
them
they feel pretty good they actually feel
a little bit firmer the playstation home
button has been replaced it used to be a
circular button
now it's just the playstation logo but
obviously it's actually quite it's
hidden quite well in there so
you're probably not going to hit that
accidentally beneath that
is another button so you can use the
dual sense controller as a microphone
seeing videos and pictures of people in
party chat and using
their dual sense to either do
text-to-speech when they're talking to
their friends and messaging them
or you can use it as a microphone so
this is a button to turn your microphone
on and off if you don't want to use that
feature
beneath it you have a headphone jack
where you can plug in just your regular
headset
if you have an old headset that you're
plugging in you want to use it as a
microphone or just for the headphones
you can plug it in
there it also has kind of a texturized
plastic on the back so you don't feel
like you're going to drop it it's not
smooth
like the dual shock it feels nice it
feels weighty the options button is now
gone it no longer says
options instead you have this button
here which serves as a replacement
word options is gone you just got the
three lines and on the other side the
share button is gone
this time around it's the create button
uh it has
three lines going in different direction
but this is the button you'd hit
to take screenshots video clips and then
mark them up and share them with your
friends
and so this is everything that you get
in the accessories box
okay time to get the console out
okay
but yeah before we take a look at the
console i'm quickly
just going to put the base on so taking
a look at the instructions
seems very straightforward so we're
going to have it horizontal
i just have to line up
these and that's it that's strange it
didn't give me any click
or any feedback but that is on there
so there you go
that was very easy the one thing i'll
say is that not having any kind of
click feedback did make me question as
to whether i'd done it correctly but
we're in so this is the playstation 5
console with the disk drive
in the horizontal position i'll adjust
it and put it in the vertical in a bit
let's take a look at the back of the
console this is where your ac power
cable is going to go
hdmi ethernet and two usb
3s be careful when you are spinning your
console around so because the base is uh
if it's in a horizontal position it's
just kind of gripping on
the bottom of the base obviously grips
to the table and it can accidentally
swing off so be very careful let's look
at the front of the console this is
obviously what you'll be looking at most
of the time
so we actually have a button
a power button the playstation 4 button
you can you know accidentally caress and
it'll turn on
uh it's also kind of difficult to find
like it's in the grooves of your console
but this one is an actual button on the
front
so there's your power button you also
have a disk release button this is
obviously the disc version so here's the
disk drive right down here
and moving along you've got a usbc port
as well as a usb one
so this is probably the one that you're
gonna plug your controller into
it's usbc on the dual send side on this
side it's just usb
let's talk about the fans then obviously
the reason the playstation 5 is so big
is because it has a huge
internal fan the plates are also there
to help
airflow so what i'm gonna do is i'm
going to set this into
vertical stand mode and then let's take
a look at the fans so actually i might
as well just walk you through it while
we're here
rotate in opposite directions here click
click so then what we have to do is
place the console up like this
and remove the screw hole cap here
got it and then we remove the screw from
in here
then all we do hang that on there again
there's no like
there's no purchase on this end so
you're just kind of like putting the
screw in and hoping for the best
so then you have the screw hole cover
and i will warn you now
this thing is slippery be very careful
uh we just had to break for a couple
minutes because i dropped this
okay so that's nuts cats
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
uh i don't know where it went oh my god
it
i it may have even gone underneath one
of these legs oh it's not it it was a
piece of dirt
what a stupid little piece uh but
if you are careful it lives
in there and clicks in so now we have
the base on
and this is the console all stood up now
that the console is stood up let's take
a closer look at the vents
which will help the console to hopefully
stay cool from the front you can see a
bunch of the vents
a lot on top but really it is the back
of the console
where there were a ton of vents to help
airflow
playstation 5 and sony they've been
talking a lot about how the playstation
5 system is going to be
remaining cool they've talked about the
fan they've talked about the liquid
metal cooling
so fingers crossed it doesn't go the way
of the playstation 4. i know that
personally
my playstation 4 right now if i boot up
something like avengers or warzone
the fan is working overtime and is
really really loud so hopefully we won't
get that with a playstation 5.
[Music]
so there you have it that's what's
inside the playstation 5 box
keep your eyes peeled to gamespot.com
and youtube.com gamespot because we're
going to be putting this thing
through its paces heat storage and of
course all the games
we're going to be covering it all so
stay tuned
[Music]
you